[Music]
on this Friday night pandemic
projections what disease models reveal
about the potential death toll in
Ontario anyone and everyone is that risk
the sobering worst-case scenario and
what we can all do to help save lives
the push back after President Trump
orders 3m to stop sending masks to
Canada having the necessary personal
protective equipment is a matter of life
and death I just can't stress how
disappointed I am with with President
Trump more money new details on the
Canada emergency response benefit and
making room from hotels to convention
centers the conversions under way to
house patients and frontline workers
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
Ontario Premier Doug Ford warned it
would be a wake-up call and today the
provinces public health experts laid out
in stark terms what their disease models
project these are projections not
certainties and there are best and worst
case scenarios here's the worst over the
full course of this pandemic which may
last for eighteen months or even two
years because we may have a smaller
secondary or tertiary wave had we done
nothing ontario may have suffered a
hundred thousand deaths 100,000 deaths
in a pandemic that could last 18 months
to two years
that's if no measures were put in place
to slow the spread of course there are
measures in place the economy has been
virtually shut down and everyone's been
told to stay home and stay physically
distant if that continues and if we all
obey the public health measures the
Ontario deaths toll is stooped death
toll is still projected to range between
3,000 to 15,000 well I appreciate that
to many people these will be shocking
figures where we end up depends on all
of us if we follow the rules if we do
our best to socially distance we can get
within that range and we can strive to
get as low as possible within that range
the decisions we all make now will
affect how many people die Ontario's
premier was explicit it is it it is
everyone's duty to slow down the spread
of the virus and more restrictions are
coming all industrial construction sites
except for critical projects like
hospitals and transportation will be
shut down this weekend Ford says when he
saw the projections
he knew drastic action had to be taken
over 1,600 people could be dead by the
end of April
that's 50 a day or that's two people
every hour never in our lifetime how
political leaders had to make
life-and-death decisions like they are
in this pandemic Eric Sorenson breaks
down the Ontario projections and what
needs to happen to prove them wrong
April will tell the tale in Ontario and
almost certainly everywhere in the
country the worst case almost
unthinkable a best-case still shocking
in this province without interventions
like physical distancing its projected
6000 would have died by the end of April
with current interventions the number of
dead now below 100 is still projected to
be 1,600 in four weeks Premier Doug Ford
grim but resolute the situation is
extremely serious he says lives are at
stake
if Ontarians don't avoid unnecessary
contact is a life worth going to the
beach is a life worth having a few cold
ones with your buddies in the basement
the answer is no like every province it
is touch and go whether Ontario
hospitals will be able to accommodate
the surge in patients who will need
intensive care beds soon here's the
current situation in Ontario right now
there are just under 200 kovat 19 cases
confirmed in ICU beds the capacity in
the province has another 400 beds
available in a best-case scenario though
the capacity is not going to be enough
the number of cases this month is
projected to rise above a thousand
however there is also a plan for an
additional nine hundred beds to increase
that capacity to meet with enough beds
for the people that will need ICU
treatment in a worst-case scenario
however there will not be enough beds
available which is why in this province
and across the country the measures
being taken are so important Ontario
hospitals have permission to increase
capacity quickly some of them are using
space in retirement homes and some of
them are actually creating field
hospitals there is reason for optimism
early projections look even worse very
clearly the pain we've gone through in
the last two weeks has been largely
successful so we have dramatically
changed the course of this epidemic here
in Ontario here in Canada and so more
measures are coming like curbside pickup
for some businesses and if we work
together we can write the last chapter
of our story the story will not end soon
but what happens in April could define
the course of the disease for months to
come
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto so
those are the projections here's where
we're at right now in Ontario there has
been another big spike in new cases more
than 460 people were confirmed positive
today
the total number of confirmed cases in
Ontario is now more than 3,000 and
here's a snapshot of the country Quebec
also had a big spike in new cases today
and the numbers are going up right
across the country more than 12,000
people across Canada have now tested
positive and more than 180 people have
died
we know those numbers are not the full
picture because many cases are not
confirmed too many people have not been
tested the most immediate challenge to
our health care system right now is a
lack of personal protective equipment
for frontline workers and the American
president is making things harder Donald
Trump told 3m it must stop exporting to
Canada any n95 masks made in the United
States
3m immediately pushed back it said in a
statement ceasing all export of
respirators produced in the United
States would likely cause other
countries to retaliate and do the same
as some have already done if that were
to occur the net number of respirators
being made available to the US would
actually decrease 3m makes 1 point 1
billion masks a year worldwide none in
Canada President Trump has invoked the
defense production act to produce more
supplies there he's facing growing
criticism outside the US for his
approach Mercedes Stevenson joins me now
Mercedes the president is making some
enemies in a few places right now
yeah Dona and Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau pushed back against this today
saying that it would be a bad idea and a
mistake for either country to start
restricting essential medical goods or
services and while he didn't threaten
retaliation he seemed to hint at it
noting that Canadian
Sarki and crossed the border into places
like Detroit every day to take care of
American Co vid 19 patients Christian
Freeland the deputy prime minister said
that Canada will do whatever it needs to
in its national interests but it doesn't
appear that donald trump is hearing
those appeals from north of the border
he just spoke at the White House and
this is what he had to say
both the governments of Canada and 3m
are pushing back on this DPA not export
n95 respirators yeah 3m says I don't
blame them they can push back he was
well might have me with 3m yeah I'm not
happy and the people that dealt with it
directly are not at all happy with 3m a
premier Doug Ford also not happy with
this situation this is what he said to
reporters earlier this afternoon I just
can't stress how disappointed I am with
with President Trump for making this
decision I understand you know he's
thinking I got to take care of my own
people but you know we're we're
connected and they even in saying that
I'm not going to rely on President Trump
dawna a senior Canadian official told me
that the CEO of 3m spoke to the minister
of procurement earlier today and assured
her that no shipments have been canceled
or diverted at this time we'll have to
see what happens now that President
Donald Trump has spoken again Mercedes
there is such urgency for PPE any sign
today that more is on the way no updates
on the number at this time Donna but the
premiers did talk with the Prime
Minister last night and agreed that they
need to share to make sure those who
need it most
get it New Brunswick and Newfoundland
and Labrador expected to potentially be
the worst off the government trying to
come up with innovative ways to deliver
that material when it arrives signing
essentially a deal with Amazon to make
those deliveries Donna okay
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thanks
health care workers in the u.s. are
dying and they are begging to for more
protective equipment there are now more
than a quarter of a million
firm cases of kovat 19 in the US that's
a quarter of all the reported cases in
the world
more than 500 people died in New York
stayed in just 24 hours
miss Jackson prosecco reports frontline
workers are beyond desperate see all the
rooms are filled the calls for equipment
and help are growing more desperate last
night before I went to bed
we had over 60 patients waiting for a
hospital then outside one Manhattan
hospital nurses staged a protest there
are so many patients that a 2,500 bed
filled Hospital meant for those
suffering from other illnesses is being
converted to a kovat 19 treatment center
New York City is now allowing
crematoriums to operate 24 hours a day
the state is on the verge of running out
of ventilators I'm going to sign an
executive order that says the state can
take ventilators and PPE from
institutions that don't need them now
and redeploy them to other parts of the
state this will go down in history as a
profound failure of our national
government governors are pleading for
help from Washington they've been given
just a fraction of the supplies
requested many states have refused to
issue stay-at-home orders the White
House still hasn't issued a national
directive if you look at what's going on
in this country I just don't understand
why we're not feeling that all the while
the number of dead Rises by hundreds
every day this koala virus is for real
Detroit bus driver Jason Hargrove tried
to sound the alarm about the risks he
faced transporting the public he died
from the virus this week in a city that
like New York has seen a number of
deaths and illnesses surge at an
alarming rate the Centers for Disease
Control has now formalized its
recommendation that Americans wear cloth
masks over their faces when out in
public but not surgical grade masks to
preserve them for medical workers at the
same time the White House now says that
any
one coming into regular contact with the
president or vice president will first
have to be cleared with a rapid
coronavirus test Donna Jackson Prosecco
in Washington Thanks hundreds of
Canadians from to Holland America cruise
ships are now back in Canada Canadian
passengers boarded a plane in Fort
Lauderdale Florida this morning bound
for Toronto a document obtained by
global news shows 243 passengers were
expected to board that flight they will
be screened here in Canada and subject
to mandatory 14 days self-isolation the
cruise ships one of which had confirmed
cases of kovat 19 on board were granted
permission to dock at port everglades
yesterday there's more terrible news
about that nursing home in Bobcaygeon
Ontario four more residents have died
from Kovac 19 that means 20 residents in
the 65 bed home have now died plus the
spouse of one of the residents there are
outbreaks in at least 26 long-term care
facilities and eight retirement homes in
Ontario this pandemic has left hundreds
of thousands of Canadians without jobs
we know many have applied for employment
insurance benefits and if you applied
after March 15th you could be in for a
race our chief political correspondent
David akin has been digging into this
David how is this happening well Donna
two point 1 million Canadians have
applied for employment insurance
benefits just since March the 15th and
of course the government wants to
process those applications as quickly as
it can so the solution is to roll
everyone who became or will become an AI
beneficiary after March 15th into the
Canada emergency response benefit
program the CRB is a flat rate benefit
of $500 a week it doesn't matter how
much you used to earn or how long you
were working the average e.i benefit is
$400 a week so hundreds of thousands who
just got their first or second di check
could see a race to five hundred dollars
a week and that could come as soon as
next week now the move from E I to the
CRB will be automatic if you've already
applied for AI since March 15th no need
to apply now I keep mentioning that date
March 15th those who applied for or were
receiving EIB for March 15th those
people will stay in the e I program and
will not get a raise now government
officials are acknowledging that this
seems to be a bit unfair and there is a
general commitment to try to deal with
this later but right now the goal for
the government is not elegant program
design the goal of the government is
speed it's to get the money out the door
as quickly as possible and they believe
this is the way to do it now
a couple of other points about the CRB
it is available not just for those who
would qualify for e aí but for anyone
who has lost work because of kovat 19
and that includes the self-employed
contract workers and so on you can apply
for the CRB beginning April 6th through
the Canada Revenue Agency now the CRA
says it has built a system that will be
able to take in and process 1 million
applications per day by phone and let's
hope they're right because the CRA also
says they're expecting 3 million
Canadians to apply on the day the gate
opens Donna Wow David the prime minister
also had news about the GST rate rebate
What did he say well the big news is the
money is going to get out the door
faster than anticipated the Prime
Minister had earlier said that he was
going to double this year's annual GST
rebate to $400 for a single person or
$600 for a couple and now we're learning
that this one-time payment to 11 point 1
million Canadians is going to be direct
deposited or mailed on April the 9th
Donna all right David akin in Ottawa
thank you a glimmer of hope in Spain
coming up some optimism in a country
where so many lives have been
Spain has recorded the first decline in
the daily death toll from kovat 19 in
over a week 932 people died from the
virus in 24 hours it's still a
staggering number but it's down from 950
people the day before the two
back-to-back days still rank has some of
the highest for the number of deaths
however the daily rise is now slowing in
Spain and has hoped the country may have
reached the peak of its outbreak the
fired commander of a US Navy aircraft
carrier got a hero's send-off as he left
the ship captain Brett Crozier was
relieved of his duties after raising the
alarm about an outbreak of kovat 19 on
his ship his letter accusing his
superiors of not protecting the sailors
was leaked to the media
the Navy now says Crozier will be
reassigned not kicked out of the Navy at
least 137 sailors from the USS Theodore
Roosevelt have tested positive for kovat
19 still ahead pop up hospitals race to
take the pressure off our health care
system
a number of cities in Canada are
scrambling to get field hospitals set up
and running
hospitals are often at capacity during
the ordinary flu season so with the
expected surge of kovat 19 cases getting
more beds in place is a matter of life
and death
Jeff simple explains this Canadian
charity responds to disasters around the
world from the earthquake in Haiti to
the Ebola outbreak in Sierra Leone but
they're now looking to deploy their
resources on home turf we've offered up
our critical infrastructure tenting you
know these big tents that we use as
field hospitals but so far only a couple
of hospitals have taken them up on the
offer
if we're gonna need field hospitals
we're gonna need them in the next two
weeks so it's not something that you can
turn around on a dime these makeshift
field hospitals providing space for more
beds and medical supplies are slowly
sprouting up in communities across the
country
Vancouver's iconic Convention Center is
making room for around 270 beds
well Edmonton's butter domes sports
arena will soon be used to treat dozens
of kovat 19 patients with milder
symptoms this hospital in burlington
southwest of toronto is now a
construction zone working to nearly
double its number of hospital beds
experts say these projects are a great
start but we've got a long way to go
canada has around 3,200 intensive care
beds that's about half as many as other
developed countries according to the
OECD despite spending more on health
care Nicole by nineteen aside the flu
season many hospitals and we're not
different from that have been running at
110 to 120 percent occupancy just with a
regular flu so far about 10 percent of
Canada's cases have required
hospitalization and the outbreak in
other countries has shown a direct link
between the number of available ICU beds
and patient deaths once you run out of
ICU capacity your metallica rate does
increase certainly because some of those
patients you could have saved if they
would have gone on a ventilator Ontario
plans to provide 900 new ICU beds just
enough for the provinces projected best
case scenario Jeff sample Global News
Burlington Ontario checking in the next
the hotels housing Canadians in need
this virus is killing business
everywhere and we know so many of you
are hurting that includes hotels many
have shut down those that are still open
or becoming a place of refuge for all
kinds of people who have nowhere else to
go Ross Lauren reports in the Montreal
suburb of Laval this is less a hotel
than it is a field hospital all of the
hotel staff is is not there they've been
replaced with hospital staff the
hospital is essentially at least out the
hotel and are operating that as I was a
hospital with 90 percent of hotel rooms
in Canada suddenly empty a growing
number are being repurposed these are
and not buyers patients these are these
are patients that are in the hospital
for other reasons and they're relocating
them - you know - and in this case our
hotel and other hotels across the
country this heritage hotel in downtown
Toronto could be forced to close because
of the devastating drop in revenue until
then it's offering rooms to nurses we
reached out to the nurses association
and to the hospital network to let them
know that we are offering a heavily
discounted rate just to support them so
that they're not having to stay in tents
in their garages at home or commute back
and forth from work a spirit of goodwill
is growing with some hotel franchisees
offering rooms for free the new
arrangements are not only for healthcare
this Halifax Hotel is hosting almost 300
Navy sailors there being isolated in
their rooms for 14 days then they'll be
at sea on standby for pandemic response
makeshift arrangements that everyone
hopes are strictly short-term Ross Lord
cool news and that is global national
for this Friday from Windy Vancouver I'm
Donna freezin we leave you tonight with
a big sign of hope from the town of
Richa bucko New Brunswick lobster traps
lifting spirits thanks for watching Rob
and Gil we'll be at the anchor desk this
weekend and I'll see you on Monday take
yourselves bye-bye